مادلين طبر ممثله وفنانه مشهوره لعبت
ادوار مهمه في الدراما والسينما العربيه
بداياتها كانت مع مجال الصحافه وربما جسدت
هذا الدور في مسلسلها الاخير ملف سري الذي
عرض رمضان الماضي دخلت عالم التمثيل من
بوابه السينما لتبدا شهرتها بعد في
الميكروفون والوصول الى ايلات صوتها لا
يزال عالقا في اذهان جيل التسعينات اذ
قامت باداء اصوات عدد من الشخصيات
الكرتونيه الشهيره في العالم العربي اليوم
في رصيدها العديد من الاعمال الفنيه
المهمه موزعه بين الدراما والسينما ولعل
اخرها الفيلم الكوميدي نبيل الجميل اخصائي
تجميل مع محمد هنيدي
رمضان ده ايه اللي حصل بقى اعتذرتي ليه عن
اعمال كلميني عن فوازير اللي بتعمليه
بتوصلي لمرحله من عمرك لازم تاخذي قرارك
يعني مش انه اجيني ثلاث مسلسلات وفي غيري
ما عم يشتغل وبيقولوا انه كيف تجرقي او
بتقدري اعصابك تقول لا قله الا توازي قيمه
الاه لقيتم مش بمستوى سنه الماضي ملف سري
قدمني كما يجب ان اقدم كشخصيه وفي شروط
اخرى انتاجيه وين نحط اسمك او مصرياتك
فاخذت قرار لا لثلاثه مسلسلات وماني
ندمانه وعم بعمل اذاعه
الشعب المصري كتير بحب الاذاعه هلا
بتشوفيهم قاعدين عم بتسمعوا اللي جايين
السواقين بالسياره بالعربيه اذا يجب ان
تصلي الى موقع ما والى مكان ما ان تعرفي
ان تقولي لا لانها توازي النعم وربما افضل
لان انت قلتي رفضتي ثلاث ادوار بتدوري على
ايه دلوقتي انت وصلتي للمرحله دي ايه اللي
بتبصي عليه الدور ولا الكاتب ولا الموضوع
ولا حجمه ولا ان هو يتعرض في رمضان هي
توليفي على بعض يعني لازم اعرف دوري مش
ضروري يكون هو دور البطوله يعني انا في
ملف سري كنت مع نجوم كبار مثل حبيبي هاني
سلامه ولكن قدمت كما يجب ان تقدم هذه
الشخصيه كتابه المخرج الانتاج
المصاري قديش يندفع لك اسمك وين حينزل هي
توليفي كامله مع مع مين عم تشتغلي يعني
انا اذا في ممثل حيتعبني ممكن ارفض يعني
بعد وصلت لمرحله انه والله لا بشتغل فيه
هذه لكن في ممثلات ما بتفرق معهم بشتغلوا
بشتغلوا اي شيء شغل انا ما بعتبر التمثيل
شغل مازلت رغم 35 36 سنه مازلت بحس اني
بستمتع واني هاويه واني لازم اروح انبسط
[موسيقى]